[Music]
it's one of the most popular sports on
the planet with both men and women
so why are so many professional tennis
players still struggling to make a
living
if you want to do this you have to
invest in yourself it's big risk but
it's also a really big reward it's
completely dependent on your results if
you have a bad year you could work an
entire year at a loss who is in charge
of the rules of tennis everybody and
nobody right people outside the sports
world think everyone's making a ton they
are not it is tough
my name is alyssia barnett i'm 28 years
old i live with my dad
when i'm not on the road and this year
i've been
on the road more than i've been home hi
i'm liam brody i'm 27 years old i'm from
stockport great britain this is the best
year of our career
it's hard to not
get consumed by thinking about prize
money a lot
but at the end of the day
you have to
go to a tournament and realize that
you're investing in
in yourself and in your tennis
there's a lot of pressure to perform
well at tournaments if you don't do well
you can be working at quite a loss so
it's a pretty
unstable income at the end of the trip
you sum everything up and you think okay
i've done well this week and it is a
little bit calming
so you come away feeling better that
you've made made a profit or you've
broken even and you can relax a little
bit but it's an afterthought if i'm
playing good enough tennis then the
money will take care of itself i think
my roommates just come in the reason
luke's here is you know to save money
basically
[Music]
so there are really seven different
stakeholders within tennis the itf
looks after the junior up to the
professional ranks and beyond that we
have the men's tour the atp the women's
tour the wta and then you have the four
grand slam events
and those seven stakeholders together
work on promoting and developing the
sport around the world well we clearly
under monetize we have a billion fans
you know we are very popular and we have
a very gender neutral fan base but we
are extremely fragmented we have all
this different organization in the pwta
the forced lambs and itf that go to
market completely separately differently
with different governance so we don't do
a great job in selling and distributing
our sport that's where we have to do
better in tennis we're probably the
fourth or fifth largest watch sport in
the world and we get very little in
media content except for the majors that
i'd like to see change
with a billion fans tennis is among the
most watched sports in the world but it
accounts for less than two percent of
global sports media rights which were
worth a total of 44.6 billion dollars in
2020
that means less money to trickle down to
the players
[Music]
it's 6 45 in the morning
feels like a very early start over here
in brest in france
let's hope we get a seat on this train
yeah life on the road i mean it's
it can be difficult at times but you do
get used to it and it's a lifestyle at
the end of the day i mean you're
probably away from home really for 40
weeks a year
you share stories about how you ended up
staying in a brothel because it was the
cheapest thing
or you're eating oats in the room rather
than paying for breakfast just to save a
little bit of cost
[Music]
most prize money goes to the top players
as you go down the ranks it drops off
steeply
[Music]
this year in the top 500 median earnings
from prize money were around 137 000 for
men and 92 thousand dollars for women
[Music]
if you're one of the top players you'll
be earning millions of dollars in prize
money as well as sponsorship deals
lower ranked players may get some extra
help from grassroots funding and free
rackets and clothes in return for social
media promotion
but the majority of their earnings will
come from winning on court
more than a third of the women and
nearly a quarter of the men in the top
500 have taken home less than fifty
thousand dollars this year
when i've asked players you know how
much money do you have to earn to make
it and most of them come up with 100 to
150 000 that's a lot of money at the
moment the current pie let me put it
that way you know the total revenue
generated by
the tennis professional sport and what
we distribute in prize money
doesn't allow for the second tier to
have
players that can make a living and
sustain the cost
[Music]
you can't argue that the best players
deserve the most money at the end of the
day tennis is a business and you want to
keep your most valuable assets happy and
that's that's the same in any business
the top three or four men top three or
four women that drive
drive ticket sales i would debate maybe
just the best players get the most money
but just maybe a little bit
less and they should
share the spread of the rest of the
money it's difficult because you think
well
they've worked really hard and they
they've they're very talented they
deserve to be there
and
if we work hard enough
we can get there too
all the grand slams have moved to give
more money to the players who get
knocked out in the early stages and
british players for example can also
benefit from pro scholarships and
tournament bonuses but many top 500
players don't make it to the slams
they play most of their season on the
second tier challenger tour and contend
with injury losing streaks and high
costs with few guarantees of financial
returns
i mean i think that you've seen a real
concerted effort by the tennis
stakeholders together and distributing
the money so that more players are able
to make you know proper earning it used
to be a little bit more top-heavy
whereas now
you know if you lose in the first round
of a grand slam tournament in singles
alone you're going to earn about fifty
thousand dollars i made the second round
of wimbledon this year and that's kind
of my
way of paying my coach and my physio and
my snc coach for the next year and to be
able to you know afford the
tennis tour really at some point you
have to draw a line and beyond that line
i think we have to be honest and say
in the challenger 2 you should be able
to at least break even and pay your cost
but you have to be conscious that this
is sort of like a university that's an
investment for you then go and move into
the professional tour where you have a
job
currently stretching up in the gym here
in bratislava after a
good session on tomorrow against ilya
marchenko
he's a
good player played him last week as well
in bergamo obviously we got the hotel
for free at the challenges which is a
nice bonus prize money came to about
1500 euros i think but then of course i
need to
pay for my coaches food and bills and
his his weekly fee as well probably
working at a loss last week that
tends to be the way that it works at
most of these tournaments i don't think
it will ever be possible to have a
sustainable tour at that level simply
because it lacks the interest of the fun
and the engagement of the sponsors
broadcasters and ticket revenues billie
jean serves for match point
beautiful shot and the wimbledon title
is hers
billie jean king won 12 grand slam
singles titles
she's even better known for fighting for
equal pay for women
in the early 70s one of her aims was
this
if you're good enough to make a living
very few people were going to be
included in that first go around because
we knew
we had to start small we're going to
make it
was that our goal absolutely not our
goal is more is the merrier
i personally would like to figure out
how we can have
at least 700 or 800 people making a
living that would make me happy because
that's the nba that's major league
baseball
[Music]
every time i wake up in the morning i
think about it i have my blessing list
but then i think okay we gotta do better
today we gotta make it work
in 2020 wimbledon and other events were
cancelled but the pandemic was also an
opportunity
to be honest i'd probably say only
since kobit have i started to be able to
make money and actually put a little bit
away into savings and that's you know at
the age of 26 i've been a professional
tennis player for you know six seven
years before that during kobe we had a
lot of tournaments in britain and there
were no outgoings tennis did come
together we had a what we called a
player relief fund
where we gave to you know the top 750
players in the world you know we
moved roland garros in september we had
to change the calendar we changed the
ranking
we got a lot closer to wta i'm a very
strong
believer that the two tours should be
combined because together we are
stronger we shouldn't be competing with
one another we should be kind of
competing with the outside world and i
think that's that's part of the strategy
with the help of an advisor we we are
sort of in the process of evaluating the
different options of how can we create a
new governance that can enable us
ultimately
for
providing the better product to defend
because at the moment if you ask
yourself the question who is in charge
of the rules of tennis the answer is
everybody and nobody right
if the atp and the wta were to merge
which would
thrill me it's got to be 50 50. you've
got to fight for each other when you're
together you need to have equal prize
money equal everything
meanwhile men's number one novak
djokovic co-founded the professional
tennis players association
he's said he wants more transparency in
tennis and to improve livelihoods
low earnings from prize money can mean
some players never get their chance on
court i think the damage to the sport is
is pretty massive uh if if the wealth
isn't spread to the to the lower players
i think there are a lot of players then
that
like i said are incredibly talented and
never get the chance to achieve their
greatest tennis there could be guys that
unfortunately don't live in a nation
where you have a strong federation which
is capable of subsidizing your cost and
then you might actually lose that talent
that could become a great champion in
the future we are addressing it is it
perfect absolutely not and we know it
it'll never be perfect no sports ever
perfect no business is ever perfect
i think it's quite a miracle that we
have we're doing as well as we are
i spent my last 10 days of the year at
the davis cup supporting the squad
practicing with them getting them ready
i basically spent the last couple of
months backpacking across europe really
felt really good coming home
you may not start out playing tennis for
the money but the money can be a game
changer
i i actually figured out as well i spend
about 12 000 pounds a year on on
stringing and rackets so you know at the
end of the day this sport is incredibly
expensive at the highest or what at the
higher levels
you always have to make sacrifices for
things that you want to do just really
grateful that i'm able to play tennis
and travel
and i'm grateful that i have that
support network because otherwise i
don't think i'd be able to do it
to be top 200 in the world or top 250 in
the world it's a remarkable achievement
out of i think seven billion people you
know it's it's
not many people who can say that
obviously if you can become good enough
then you can earn a living at the sport
but sometimes it's not that easy
a lot of kids will come up to me say you
think i should try or not i tell them
always try because you do not want to
say when you're older i should have
tried ever you don't want to ever say
that i should have could've could
so i think it's really important to give
it a go
because you know what if you do make it
you're one of the elite you get lucky in
life and there's opportunities you
could never dream up
[Music]